that's the very moment that started like
a four-year depression for me
t-pain is opening up about his battle
with depression
in netflix's new docu-series this is pop
the rapper reveals the dark side of his
musical success
which includes the infamous introduction
of autotune to mainstream music
while the pitch correction technology
has been around for years
it helped propel t-pain to super stardom
and the rapper claims his use of
auto-tune
led to a confrontation with usher t-pain
recalls being on a flight with the yeah
singer in
2013. t-pain says he fell asleep and was
woken up by a flight attendant who said
that usher would like to speak with him
so i got up and went back and he was
like you know how's everything going
quick small talk no big deal and
he was like man i want to tell you
something man that's like what's what's
good i thought he's about to tell me
something real
he sounded real concerned he was like
man you kind of
kind of [ __ ] up music
the rapper explains that he thought
usher was joking at first so he laughed
but according to t-pain usher allegedly
doubled down on his comment
i didn't understand usher was my friend
he was like nah man you really like you
really [ __ ] up music for real singers
literally at that point i couldn't
listen
is he right did i
did i [ __ ] up music the bartender singer
says that alleged conversation
took a toll on him i don't even think i
realized this for a long time that's the
very moment
that started like a four-year depression
for me
e.t reached out to a rep for usher who
was not available for comment
as for t-pain he took to twitter on
tuesday after the docu-series was
released
to clarify that he still loves and
respects usher
adding quote telling that story was in
no way meant to disrespect that man
people talk about me 24 7 but when it
comes from someone you truly respect
it hits very different i never said oh
sure
it was a drop in the ocean of [ __ ] i was
already going through
the rapper's use of auto-tune was met
with a wave of backlash
in 2009 jay-z even recorded an entire
diss track
attacking the pitch correction titled
doa
death of auto-tune this is
anti-auto-tune
that for the ringtone this ain't for
itunes this ain't for single loss
but since then t-pain has achieved
plenty of success
dropping an album co-writing a cocktail
book
and he even went on to win the first
season of the masked singer
i didn't have a chance to come into the
game with my natural voice and you know
a lot of my peers did and they get
accepted this helped me
get my voice out there even more e.t
caught up with a
year old musician after his big win and
he opened up about why the whole thing
made him emotional
you know just to hear all the the
compliments and to hear
everybody praising you so much it was it
was uh it was pretty cool it's pretty
cool to hear that and
you know it's always the you know don't
cry because once you get going you're
going to get me going
it was always there but you know to see
to see them appreciate what i did so
much it was it was pretty cool
[Applause]
it was crazy because they were genuinely
surprised and i think people were
surprised that you had that voice
because we usually hear you
automatically yeah and that that makes
sense i mean
it's it was normal to me because you
know i hear my voice all the time but
you know when people hear the auto tune
they you know automatically go off of
well that can't be his real voice
and you know it's it's pretty much the
same it's pretty much the same
why the heck didn't you ever just sing
to us then because i was just being
another singer there was nothing that
would have set me apart from everybody
else it was just been another guy with a
voice
you know we i think we think we got a
good amount of those
not only is t-pain full of talent he's
funny too
what's the recipe for macaroni and
cheese the rapper recently posted
this clip to his instagram page
revealing that he's been
accidentally ignoring tons of dms from
celebs for years
i was today years old when i found out
about the requests folder on instagram
that's full of celebs trying to reach me
dude is that fergie smh
i've been accidentally straight up
ignoring all these people for like two
years
i thought dms are supposed to just show
up in the normal folder
and you don't have to go digging for all
these yeah we're talking dms from stars
like viola davis
and diplo just to name a few i apologize
to everybody on this list
and the hundreds of others i couldn't
fit in this video
these are just the ones i haven't
checked and replied to
yup i'm stupid
luckily t-pain has seemingly figured it
out and now he's enjoying the perks of
connecting with some major vips
check your [ __ ] dms and see
who's in your mdm because sometimes
sometimes sometimes sometimes it might
be somebody
really damn important